Tìm em không càng thóa quần xói gần hay sao
Là thay em xa đất tình
Anh là mùi lời em lên lì
Baby, bây lòng này đời
Sao giám ơi đất tình thế nào
Thật lòng như nồi sao ngoài kì chăm con
Hay là pháo đất quá tên
Sứng tập nếu là mục qua sao
At thần trên cao nếu anh nhi bên cạnh
Bây biệt vì mai
Đó là in lì
Lầm mi yêu anh nhi em đó là tình vì
Mà thế giải mi nhìn người đứng tình
Nhìn muốn tăng như đáp cơm không đi
Sao lại còn phải bánh nhạc
Để đo em cũng gà chơi
Anh có chung là đa dương của bơm
Thì ra đây, baby
Nó anh em có đêm bánh nhạc
Nha
Anh có nói rồi bao giờ đó
Chuyệt anh không
Mà ho khoảng phát trái đằng sau
Baby, em ơi
Sai em có thế không biết
Em không biết em không biết được hiểu nha
Bình như em không có thôi
Phần sau thường này sau
Hey là thay em xa đất tình
Anh gà muốn được em lên thuyền
Baby, baby
Baby, lâu này là đau
Sao phải mời được nhìn anh em
Thật lòng như ngon sau
Qua kia chẳng thó ai là